here now with reaction Texas Senator Ted
Cruz Senator you were one of the few out
there warning seeing the evidence that
was coming in that this in fact came out
of this lab it made sense from the
beginning and they lied about it they
covered it up
well Sean that's exactly right as I sit
here and listen to those uh folks on TV
and and read those headlines it makes me
angry because they're lying they're
deliberately lying they knew they were
lying they are repeating the talking
points of the Chinese communist
government Democratic politicians were
doing that and the corporate media was
doing that it has been evidence the
overwhelming weight of the evidence for
for over two years now has been that
this virus escaped from a Chinese
government lab and what's happened this
weekend is we now have the bombshell
report that not one but two agencies in
the Biden Administration have concluded
the coronavirus came the covid-19 virus
came from a Chinese government lab
number one the Biden FBI has concluded
that and number two this weekend we
learned their reports that the Biden
energy department has concluded covid-19
came from a Chinese government lab now I
can tell you more than two years ago in
in March and April of 2020 on my podcast
verdict with Ted Cruz that we put out
every week I laid out the evidence then
that it was obvious this came from a
Chinese government lab let me point to
three facts that are compelling number
one the Wuhan Institute for virology
which studies not just viruses studies
coronaviruses not just coronaviruses
coronaviruses derived from bats is
located just a couple hundred yards from
the wet Market where this outbreak first
occurred in Wuhan China by the way those
bats don't occur naturally in China any
closer than 900 miles away and yet a few
hundred yards from the lab that's where
the the outbreak occurred data point
number two in November of 2019 before
the pandemic three separate researchers
at the Wuhan Institute for virology were
hospitalized went and checked themselves
in for serious ailments ailments that
suggest that they may have been the very
first people with covid-19 in fact that
might have been how it escaped
fact number three
after the pandemic began the Chinese
government actively destroyed the
samples at the Wuhan Institute for
virology destroyed them and they also
disappeared the whistleblowers now I'll
tell you in a court of law if you're
facing a subpoena and you go and Destroy
evidence
you can be held liable for that but not
only that the judge will instruct the
jury to draw an inference against you
that if you're destroying evidence it's
because the evidence demonstrates your
guilt in this instance the fact that
China's first reaction was get rid of
all the evidence shows that they knew
they covered it up China Bears the
responsibility and the entire corporate
media media CNN MSNBC all of the
alphabet soup The Washington Post the
New York Times not only did they not
cover this
they eagerly repeated the Democrat
talking points and the talking points
from the Chinese communist government it
was dishonest and and profoundly corrupt
the senator we know the China lied we
know that we fund the who we give them a
fortune millions and millions of dollars
they lied we know that our own
government got it wrong about masks we
know they got it wrong about vaccines
everything they turned told us turned
out not to be true how could we ever
trust them again
look Sean that that is a huge problem
you know you look at Dr fauci there is
no bureaucrat in the history of our
country who has done more damage to the
United States than Dr Anthony fauci
number one his recommendations resulted
in shutdowns that hurt tens of millions
of kids destroyed millions of jobs
millions of small businesses and his
willingness
to set aside science to set aside data
and to be purely political there has
been nothing in our lifetimes that has
done more to damage The credibility of
government scientists or doctors than Dr
Anthony fauci there are now tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions of
Americans that are not going to believe
the next thing a scientist or doctor
working for the government says and
that's dangerous if God forbid we have
another pandemic let's say we have
something like Ebola that has massively
High fatality rates I want us to be able
to have scientists and doctors that can
give us advice on how to keep our
families safe and yet fauci was so
willing to listen to the teachers union
so willing to listen to the Biden White
House so willing to put politics above
science that he has done enormous damage
to the credibility of of of the
government doctors I I think that's an
incredible disservice to the country
Senator very powerful statement
um I can't say it anybody or Senator Ted
Cruz thank you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else